you can see france from here and you can
see the world of trade
but now the gap between britain and
europe
is starting to feel wider today after
reflecting on the state of trade talks
the prime minister said the uk
should prepare itself for a no deal
brexit
for whatever reason it's clear from the
summit that after 45 years
of membership they are not willing
unless there's some fundamental change
of approach
to offer this country the same terms as
canada
and so with high hearts and with
complete confidence we will prepare to
embrace
the alternative government sources went
even further claiming trade talks were
dead
unless the eu fundamentally changed its
position
a few hours later it emerged that plans
to resume talks on monday
had been cancelled for the moment
negotiations
really have come to a halt a no deal
brexit
is closer than ever there are plenty
here in brussels who think that boris
johnson delivers these threats as a
sort of voter-pleasing rhetorical
flourish rather than with
any real purpose or menace the leaders
who
gathered here were unanimous in saying
they wanted a brexit deal but not at
any price so the chance of the eu
now having that fundamental change of
heart
do seem vanishingly small but in
brussels
we didn't have much sign of a
rapprochement the french president keen
to appear strong in front of voters
and especially french fishermen was
resolute
the state of our talks is not that we
are stumbling over the issue of fishing
which is the main
argument made by the british but we're
stumbling over everything
everything it's not the job of the
leaders of the remaining 27 member
states who
chose to remain in the eu to make the
british prime minister happy
but here they are trying to remain
optimistic
there is agreement that europe at a time
of covet resurgence
would much prefer a deal we are
totally united totally determined to
work
in order to make an agreement possible
but not at any cost
uh and what we said yesterday uh remains
right um today and you know that
michelle barney is committed to
leadership
we are ready to negotiate these leaders
know that time is running out just
10 weeks now until the end of the year
but if talks really have come to an end
then we're in new territory no deal now
looks
the more likely option adam parsons sky
news